[Music]
[Applause]
luna
the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys anna welcome back to the lehigh
pen show
um let me know if you can hear me okay
because i have changed my
mic so it should be a little different
to
usual so when you guys comment i've got
all the comments on so i can see
everything um coming through okay so
this show
is a little different um a little bit
nervous because it's a bit different
um was also quite last minute um because
i'd just been
working on my book all day um had no
makeup on my face whatsoever so i
thought okay i'll just throw something
on and just do this
show okay so before we jump in
um of course it is powered by um icon
plus capital
it is sponsored by um block fi so you
can actually get up to 250
um when you sign up i hope i wrote that
correctly um an actual new sponsor that
i have this week
is compass so some quick information
about compass so
basically um compass they are a company
that make
bitcoin mining accessible for everyone
so you can actually get a machine
pick a hosting facility and let them do
the work so if you do want um
some kind of bitcoin mining facility
then definitely head to compassmining.io
so they are the newest sponsors on my
show so it's really exciting
okay so i said i'd do an ama
so that's what i'm gonna do we're also
gonna talk about my book which i've been
rewriting today actually um because i
had a change of heart about a few things
so
this is totally live as you guys know
this is completely
unprepared it was a really last minute
so i'm gonna head over to twitter now
and have a look at some of the questions
that you guys sent me
because yeah this is totally live
unprepared
have a thought about haven't even looked
at the questions yet it's just been such
a hectic day
so let's have a look okay so crypto
chris
so made a shout out to cryptochrist
because he is great he always um
interacts with everything
love his takes so he asks what my
favorite books are
fiction and non-fiction okay so somebody
actually asked me this
the other day did someone very blink if
this is live this is totally live
and unprepared i haven't even seen the
questions yet so i'm just doing it as
they as they come to me
okay so favorite book somebody asked
this um the other day so i'm actually
really into um i don't know if i'd call
it spirituality but i'm definitely into
like the mind body connection and how
um your your every every everything that
you feel
physically is a result of what's going
on in your mind so one of my favorite
books is actually the biology of belief
and mind over medicine so that comes
from a very
personal story i had a bunch of health
issues when i was younger
and i read those books and i'm amazing
i'm all happy and healthy today
um in terms of other books um i'm
actually not a huge
reader when i read it's to learn
something so like i said biology of
belief was to help with my physical
life um and then i absolutely love all
the bitcoin books um i'm a big fan
of um bitcoin and black america
um by isaiah jackson that was so
fascinating
love jason williams's book if you guys
haven't seen that check it out
um you know hard money you can't f with
i'm not gonna swear because this is
youtube
um so yeah those are some of my some of
my favorite books
somebody said did your brother sell his
bitcoin for ethereum actually my brother
owes me a lot of money and he's gonna
have to sell his bitcoin to pay me back
this money
um which i will tell you all about
another time i asked him to
tell me more information about this and
if i can post about it but he won't
let me do it yet but i'm definitely
gonna have him on the podcast so stay
tuned for that because my brother is
quite a coiner um he can't help it
he was once up like a few weeks ago
um like at the top of the bull market
back in april he was up
70 grand on some coin he didn't sell it
he's now
totally minus so so there you go he's a
he's a bit of a coiner he'd message
me
because he was in the states and i was
in um the uk he'd message me at like 1am
my time
leo you need to get in on this on this
thing it's called like moon this and you
know it's
kind of rubbish so i obviously didn't
buy it um
so that's a story about my brother okay
so i'm going through some of the
questions
someone says in all serious though
comparing with the past
bear markets how long will this one last
do i think okay we can definitely talk
about this market
okay so look as you guys know it's
obviously impossible to tell what kind
of market
um we're in um if you want to talk about
um you know price depreciation everybody
was was expecting some kind of
correction
um off the top of my head again this is
all totally unprepared
um i would say this is the most
bullish bear market i have seen um i
think what we've seen right now is
absolutely unbelievable um
with what we've seen going on with el
salvador the rest of central and south
america
um you know i think china is a really
really interesting topic
to be honest the china topic i think um
is good news i'm happy to talk about
that as well because
a lot of people have been um you know
saying this is this is terrible
what we're seeing with china and i think
it's great um
for two main reasons one of the main
reasons i feel this is great is because
one of the biggest issues that bitcoin
often comes under when it you know when
it's scrutinized and all this is
centralization people say that it's
centralized in china
and this fudd is regurgitated again
and again and in some ways this is
amazing for the decentralization of the
network
um we've already seen many different
mining companies talking about moving to
kazakhstan
moving to um canada moving to the us
miami
this is great for the decentralization
of the network um
i'm just reading some of your comments
now i'm getting this is really hard by
the way to like
do a live and read the comments and read
everything that's going on
i've never done this before so this is
this is kind of strange
um so there you go those are those are
my thoughts is my thoughts on china oh
and also another point as to why this is
a good thing
so clearly china has an effect on the
market this is very much an immature
market um
bitcoin is only 12 years old we've seen
us very much correlated to geopolitical
events to some extent of course it
recovered after the crash in 2020 but
it's not immune just yet um and so
i feel china has less control
over the price or less influence over
the price in that short term um
you know especially if there's less
mining going on there so
just reading the comments people are
saying nice things thanks it's a it's
stressful this is stressful
um so yeah there you go those are those
are my brief thoughts on china i don't
think it's an issue
um i was talking about this actually
with jason williams the other day um we
were sort of saying that
things will take time to recover um
you know you don't just plug in a mining
machine and it's all just okay
although these major operations are
leaving china and they're moving to
other places
building that kind of infrastructure
takes time but i have zero worries
the difficulty adjustment adjusts i love
saying that i think it sounds really fun
um and i think it's great as well the
mining rewards have gone up i don't know
if you guys have seen that actually
the mining rewards have gone up i think
at one point um
i don't know what it was but the mining
rewards not that it's gone up but
miners now more miners are um have more
access to the rewards right because
there's less competition on the market
which is pretty cool so
what's happened with china has has
incentivized more people to get involved
i think that's great
help decentralize the network more all
right i'm going to keep going and have a
look at some other questions
and then i'm going to go into my book
because i said i'd answer that
all right let's have a look what we have
what do you spend the majority of your
money
on each month oh my god that is such a
good question um
i would say unfortunately alcohol and
coffee
is that absolutely awful um and food
i just i think i like going out for
breakfast so like avocado
eggs coffee and then wine in the
afternoon olives
i'm pretty european like that um that's
pretty much what i spent my money on but
i actually said once i've completed my
book and once it's done
i'm going to reward myself by
um by buying face creams
i mean i feel like that's you just reach
an age where you know you want to get
yourself some luxurious face creams
that's what i want to do so that's what
i'm gonna do um it's pretty expensive
actually but that's how i'm gonna
spend my money next month all right
let's have a look what else we have are
you still thinking of moving out the
country
okay so moving countries is difficult
especially
um after brexit so with brexit for those
who aren't european
um someone says i think this isn't live
this is live okay i haven't even seen
any of your questions
i'm totally just winging this because
i've been working all day i haven't had
a chance to do anything so i'm
win it winning so i can't got my words
out winging this
okay so after brexit um for those that
don't know
um when you lived in an eu country you
have what is called freedom of movement
so before brexit as a uk citizen
i had the right to pick up my stuff and
live in any eu country as they did
have the right to come to an um to come
to the uk from whatever country
you came from um after brexit that is
now not possible we can only do three
months in a particular country if i want
to live there
um you have to go through the whole
immigration process which is a nightmare
so in terms of where i want to live i'm
totally undecided
and um i don't want to go through a
whole immigration process to go
somewhere and then to decide actually i
don't want to live there um
so i really kind of want to embrace the
bitcoin digital
nomad kind of lifestyle um whereby i do
three months here i do three months
there
um and it's so much more exciting like
that especially because right now the
world is changing so much
um i'm in love with what el salvador
have done i'm totally open to spending
some time in el salvador
um i'm so open to it i can't even tell
you um
and so why would i want to go through an
entire immigration process
for a particular country when what if
the country suddenly becomes a really
anti-crypto
you know what if the country um goes
into a lockdown
the world is so unpredictable that i
don't want to be
i don't want to be tied to a certain
country you know i have the right to
live in the uk as a
um as a citizen that's been born and
raised here so you know i'm fortunate
enough to have that
um but i'm definitely gonna do some
traveling so the goal is actually
um and then we can get onto my book but
i do wanna answer more questions um
so the uh so the goal is um essentially
to come to miami
that's what i want to do so i want to
get to miami um
around the middle of august so there's
actually a conference in november
around the 10th 11th of november which i
will be
hosting um and it's in miami
so i'm only allowed to spend three
months in america
so that means that i've got to get to
miami
just after the middle of august
so because i don't know if you know but
uk citizens aren't actually allowed
to fly directly to america right now
because of covid
um so what that means is i have to then
fly to mexico spend two more two weeks
in mexico and then go to the states so
when i'm there
i wanna do um a book launch i wanna do a
major
meet up um so if you're interested then
let me know in the comments where i
should do this meet up i'm thinking of
doing it in miami
um and just hanging out there um and
that's what i want to do and then i
might go to texas
um and do a meet-up there do maybe like
some kind of book launch book signing
um so that's my thought process for
traveling okay so someone's asked a
really interesting question
i'm gonna put it on the screen so you
guys can read it and then i'm gonna take
a drink of water
because this is totally live and this is
so i'm unpredictable all right
what do you think will happen with banks
and crypto
it's a really great question one which
i've actually addressed in my book on
dressing bitcoin
okay so here's my take so today we just
heard so today is
um for those re-watching it is the
eighth of july
how time flies so um we've actually just
heard that um santander are now the
second bank in the uk
to block um payments from finance
so obviously barclays was first and uh
santander was second so i think this is
sad
and i think it's a shame and i think
it's really really upsetting
take is that people only ban
what they fear and china is a fantastic
example of that
you know china ban bitcoin because they
fear it
china ban twitter because they fear it
trying to buy many different things
because they fear it so we understand
that banning is done because they fear
it
and i tweeted about this yesterday it's
so much more
than bitcoin it's so much more than an
alternative way
for me it's about freedom and there is
this
looming war on freedom
and i think we've seen that with covet
anyway um
you know with all the lockdowns and how
different countries have approached it
differently
just as an example you know some
countries you have to wear a mask
outside
other countries you know of course you
don't have to wear a mask outside it
makes no sense for the science you know
um we've seen florida and texas have
stayed open
and nobody's dropping dead to dying um
you know nobody's dropping dead over
there so what we'll see
is certain institutions states provinces
organizations will have to pick aside as
we continue to move forward
everything right now is strange um you
know whether it's the
whether it's um in politics
with the olympics you know we see trans
women in
females female sports we're not allowed
to criticize that
hence war on speech freedom of speech
um war and money with banks and so on
and so on so basically what i'm getting
at is that we are going through a
really interesting time
we've been told that we will eventually
get to a point
whereby we're
this is what they've said to us they've
said to us you will own nothing and you
will be happy
what do you mean we will own nothing
what do you mean how does that make
sense
surely i should own what i choose to own
that's a war on individual freedom
already
we're and we've been going down this
path for a really long time i mean we
know this editor from the the messages
that i received um
after that tweet so what's gonna happen
banks institutions countries provinces
states will have to pick
a side cbdc's will come
they will try and replace
bitcoin you can't actually ban a network
like that which we've obviously spoken
about many different times
but they will try and propaganda and
marketing will be a
huge huge part of this i mean
covert has its own damn marketing
campaign vaccines have a marketing
campaign cbdc's will have a marketing
campaign
and it's our job our responsibility
to make sure that those who are not
inside
or not involved in the cryptocurrency
industry understand
that they are different and cbdc's are
highly centralized
they are not this new shiny form of
money which is going to make life better
which
is how i believe it will be sold as um
there will be a war between but a subtle
one right like when i say
when i when i talk about this war that i
envisage
it's not an obvious war it's not like
men on the streets men in the trenches
men on the fields
it's not that anymore it's a subtle war
between the people and those in control
those in power
and it's our responsibility to continue
to fight that there will it there will
be an increased crackdown on it
and like i said states organizations
provinces
countries will have to pick a side and
it's
really really interesting i think russia
actually i read yesterday so i don't
fully know the situation there but
russia
their politicians are talking about
implementing new legislation
which would allow governments to um
seize people's cryptocurrencies but it's
not clear yet
whether that will be cryptocurrencies um
which are
specifically involved in illegal
activity or
cryptocurrencies in general or
cryptocurrencies that they
suspect have been involved in illegal
activity what do you mean suspect
it's concerning there will be a war
between
the two sides i'm convinced of it and
the war is starting like i said it's
gonna be subtle
anyway i'm going to keep reading someone
says speak your truth i will always
speak my truth
okay let's have a look at the questions
that i have like i said guys this is
totally live also i didn't mention
um maybe i did but i don't remember oh i
did mention it but i'll say it again
this is powered by i'm the vc firm icon
plus capital so i just want to make
everybody aware of that okay
let's have a look oh gosh i was about to
read something out which is rude
um okay let's keep going um
why aren't you married yet um i'm not
married yet because
i am in my mid-20s
and i will be married one day at some
point okay
did you ever use btc to buy things um
not exactly so i work with
um crypto.com so they sponsor somebody
tweet some of my tweets
um but crypto.com are fantastic like
i've been i only partnered with them
about
a month ago so june i believe was my
first month
um partnering with them but i've been
using them for over a year i think since
march last year so huge fan of the
company um so in terms of do
i spend my bitcoin okay so
sometimes when somebody sends me bitcoin
like i i
settle balances with friends and family
in bitcoin so they'll send me bitcoin
and then i will top up my crypto.com
card and then spend so in that way i
spend bitcoin
other than that not really honestly um
what i
i get paid mostly in bitcoin so um i
work a lot with altcoin buzz and exodus
wallet
um so they pay all their employees
in bitcoin which is really cool so i get
paid in bitcoin um
so what i tend to do is sell it
to an extent so that i can pay my bills
on my fixes um
so that's the extent of my paying in
bitcoin
um other than that not really i live in
england there's nowhere to directly
buy things you know you could say people
use
um you know like paypal or something
like that to pay for things in bitcoin
but
it's really just an intermediary which
switches to fiat so it's the same as
crypto.com and that it switches to fiat
and then you spend it
um so not really no okay
reading more stuff let's have a look
okay oh my god so many questions coming
through this is great thank you so much
for watching
um somebody asked how can we get more
women into crypto
um everyone watching do you know my
opinion on this
before i potentially discuss it so
somebody asks
how do we get more women into crypto do
you guys know my opinion on this
i have a pretty harsh opinion on the
situation
so obviously the comments are on let me
know
okay what is my opinion on this
really it's just a question why do we
need more women in crypto
why do we need more women in crypto
i don't know why i don't think we need
more anyone in anything i think we need
more
competent qualified
qualified people that add value
to the space that is what we need i
don't want more people i don't want
more women in anything just because
they're women
not all women women don't offer an
alternative perspective
just because they're women like
absolutely not
i actually have a very masculine um
outlook on life a typically masculine
outlook on life
does that mean suddenly my opinion is
invalid because it's not a female
opinion
no i don't offer a female perspective i
i really do not offer a traditional
female perspective
so adding and i'm also you know women
are supposed to be creative
and add a nice feminine touch i'm not
like that i'm actually not very creative
at all i'm very
facts and figures and i like to follow
strategies and
i don't like to create i'm really not
good at creating so
the traditional or ideal value that a
woman offers to this space i don't
believe that i
that i bring at all i think i bring what
the men bring
the same the same kind of thing except i
look a little bit different
maybe if you guys enjoy looking at long
hair then there you go
but from uh from a different from this
kind of standpoint
i don't offer any different value
because i'm a woman whatsoever
um like i said everything that i offer
really is i i'm very masculine in that
sense you know like i like structure
and i like i like looking at like the
facts and the figures and i like
following um plans and details i don't
like to create and add that typical
feminine
um perspective so really we need more we
need more
competent people that add value whether
they're women or not that's great
for me i don't really care honestly
same goes with religion same goes with
race i'm just not interested
at all um and also just because a woman
is in a space doesn't mean that that
will represent other women
you know this is 50 of the population
we're talking about gender does not uh
put us um gender does not align us
it doesn't it doesn't make us the same
um there's a lot of women in the space
who
um i have zero things in common with um
have more
i think more things in common with men
so yeah gender is
ridiculous all right let's see what else
we have here
um okay very nice okay i'm gonna go back
to my twitter
what is your ultimate financial goal
not mentioning one specific asset okay
how long have i been live 22 minutes
okay all right i'm gonna just take a
little breather
and then um i'm gonna talk about
undressing bitcoin
okay so like i said this is totally live
was a little bit stressed out been
working all day and um
couldn't think about what i was what i
was going to do for the show
um didn't read any of the questions
beforehand i just figured
what will we all be okay so someone asks
let me read again
what are your ultimate financial goals
not to mention okay my financial goals
okay good question look
it's not a financial goal it's more just
like a life goal
the life goal is freedom freedom has
always been my goal
um i have zero problem with personal
responsibility in fact i love
personal responsibility my goal
is to live a happy beautiful and free
life
um whereby the weekends are full of
adventure
the days are full of adventure you know
i love nature
whether that's going out and you know
going to lakes watching the sunsets
going to the beach
i love nature and i want my days to be
full of nature
and a lot of the time in order to kind
of live that kind of lifestyle
you have to have money to do what you
want to do so the goal is financial
freedom i don't want my money to be
in um custody of somebody else if you
guys have been following me you'll know
that
revolut blocked my bank sorry revolut
blocks my friends
revolut are my bank their mother fintech
company um but they
they blocked my funds tonight move a bit
and get a little bit comfier
so yeah revolut blocked my funds and
that is awful
right that is so bad i had a lot of
money in these accounts and they blocked
it and so
somebody says i seem to have a problem
with authority that's funny i don't i'm
just very much pro-freedom which i think
is a wonderful wonderful thing
um why do i need authority i am my own
authority i'm very
um i trust myself to navigate my own
life i don't need somebody who knows
nothing about me to navigate my life i
only i can navigate my life
um to the best of its ability um so
revolut blocks my funds um
long story short um i don't back with
them anymore but
because i had money in cryptocurrency
held in a non-custodial way
i was able to survive um
like i said i get paid in bitcoin so the
majority of my wealth is in crypto
um is in bitcoin so because i had money
in bitcoin i was okay but
those who don't hold their money in that
manner those who are not financially
sovereign
who are who could be in my situation
where banks freeze
you know your business account your
personal account it's pretty sad so my
goal is
absolutely financial freedom someone
says but don't you enjoy the adventure
of financial freedom
and if you achieved what else you're
gonna do besides no like
okay here's my thing okay here's my
thing you know how we all used to
be cave men and women right and the men
would go out and
we all lived in nature the men would go
out they would um they would kill the
animals bring back the food and
everything right we all used to live in
those
those times before not even not even
cave men times we talked about the stone
age and all that i'm talking about like
back in the day okay everything was very
much
in nature we don't have the kind of
houses that we have today and have the
technology that we have today but
i think we're going to go back to that
because of technology
because of things like covert which has
shown us we don't need to commute and go
into the office and things like that
with this increased technology that we
have we're going to go back to that
and that's kind of what i want to do you
know that digital nomad lifestyle
where they live in beautiful places and
all this stuff they're going back to
that except they have wi-fi now
and i kind of want i kind of want that
like i want to be out in the wild
i want to be i want to do my work with
amazing wi-fi and all this stuff
and then once my day is done i want to
go and have an adventure in nature
that is my goal back how it used to be
back in the day before all technology
and stuff and that is freedom and i
think that's what like
you know things like bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies and this new technology
that we have i think that's what it will
do
people living in like listen i was i was
out in london the other night okay
it was empty it was a friday night and
it was empty why was it empty we're not
in lockdown anymore
why was it empty because what's the
point like people
aren't living in the center of the city
anymore because because of covert
because they've all gone back home they
don't need to live
right around the corner from the office
there's going to be a huge exodus from
the city
back into nature and that's what i'm
excited for
okay i'm gonna talk about my book now so
if you have any questions about my book
please just
um write them oh i'm still here let me
just change my camera hang on i'm still
here there we go
take a sip of water
okay
oh this is really strange i have never
done this before
feels weird okay i am totally live
all right so my book okay so it's called
undressing bitcoin
and here's the thing
i love this industry i've just spoken
for about
28 minutes and 11 seconds about freedom
personal responsibility being
self-sovereign
and all the things that i love and
support and appreciate now because i
love it so much i want to spread
adoption i want people to know about
this revolutionary technology
what upsets me is that i feel that right
now there's really this huge barrier to
entry
forget physical barriers to entries to
like um on and off rams and barclays and
santander and all this
stuff that i discussed at the beginning
um but a philosophical
and technological barrier to entry it's
hard
to understand what this space is really
about
you know if you just say freedom to
somebody i think you're a conspiracy
theorist
you know if you say it's your friends
down the road i believe in freedom so
i'm leaving the traditional financial
system
it's hard for people to understand
they'll literally think you are a
conspiracy
theorist um it's also very hard to
verbalize the problems with the
traditional financial system
to put forward the case for inflation
it's hard do you have the numbers off
the top of your head i'm writing this
down book and i don't even have the
numbers off the top of my head
actually i do because i wrote something
a minute ago but it's
really really hard and the technology is
hard
understanding the the importance of
decentralization that is really really
hard understanding things like um
mining it's a whole new language hash
rate
you know difficulty adjustment i mean
what the hell are these things it's so
hard but like these things are
what makes bitcoin so genius and
you know the elegance of the technology
which makes it
the most incredible piece of technology
we've ever seen so these things
are hard so my idea is to basically put
together a book which explains it and
i want the book to be full of fun like i
want it to be
spicy i want it to have personality i
want to have flavor
and i want it to be full of so much fun
and i want you to be able to take this
book and say
yeah read undressing bitcoin it's
actually bloody great
and you can fully understand the
problems of the traditional financial
system
and you probably have it off while you
while you read it as well you know like
there's such a gate there's such
gatekeeping and there's such
difficulties to get involved it's hard
to understand
what this technology is really about and
so i want yes somebody's wrote
a knowledge barrier i mean that's
exactly it you know it's so hard for
people to understand so i
and it's boring to some people okay so
here it is because my excitement for
this space comes from freedom
and my love for freedom and
understanding this looming
authoritarianism that's coming so i
ideally
if people don't feel that way they'll
find it really really boring
so i want to add as much flavor and
excitement to it that's basically the
goal
and um it's going to be very different
it's going to be um
it's going to be very unfiltered and
it's going to be quite potentially
controversial
because it's what it's going to say what
we're all thinking so i actually rewrote
the first chapter today
and in that first chapter i'm basically
roasting everyone
so i posted this on my twitter
and um people thought oh oh you're
roasting us on twitter absolutely not
you guys are great i'm not roasting you
lot i'm roasting
the federal reserve i'm roasting
jerome powell that's how you pronounce
his name i'm roasting
the education system um i'm roasting
the um bank of england everything
all the systems are getting
roasted in that first chapter okay a lot
of people
would um or how i initially wrote it was
very much
tipping tippy-toeing yeah i'm like you
know walking on thin ice
um as you go through this but screw that
honestly it's gonna be so unfiltered
um and um yeah it's gonna be completely
unfiltered and i'm gonna say what the
hell i fancy saying
um there's gonna be a lot of sarcasm in
the book um it's gonna be very witty
um yeah there's one line
um when i talk about money laundering
and i make a joke yeah there's just so
many jokes
somebody has said let's have a look how
many contributors in your book
no contributors it's just me
it's just me and it's been really really
difficult
um i actually wrote the book during the
lockdown
um and um i actually yeah i wrote it
during the lockdown so it's actually
like pretty depressing
time to write a book um so looking back
on it now i'm
definitely adding more flavor and more
energy to it
um so the book cover
is also really exciting um like i said i
want to
my goal is to um
it'll not necessarily follow all the
rules um i just want to do what i want
to do um i don't necessarily because i'm
just going to be me and i don't
necessarily want to try and fit in
you know um should i try and fit in
and be potentially
i don't know like i don't want to be
dull with things you know i want to be
exciting with things and
i don't want to um i don't want to
play by the rules i don't want to do
what everybody else has done i really
just wanna be
i wanna be uncensored and true to my
personality and true to me
um and that's how the book will be the
book will be
totally unfiltered true to me it's gonna
be completely different
to all the other books um and
yeah i just i want it to be fun
and exciting okay so when's it coming
out
um so initially um the book was supposed
to come out at the end of july which it
might still do
um but like i said i'm actually going
over it to add more flavor
and i feel like one of the things is
because you care so much about this and
i've actually never written a book
before but because i care so much about
this and i really want to make sure
that and also it's an academic subject i
want to make sure that all the
information is there
so going back i've noticed that um
going back i noticed that i put too many
examples in
okay and i need to take those out
there's so many examples of inflation
i don't need it there are so many
examples of how bitcoin can't be banned
and more news keeps coming out so i was
going to write something about china and
i was like you know i already made the
damn point move the hell on
so that's the hard part of the book
because
you want to you want it to be so perfect
and
um someone says put too many what too
many examples too many examples
to illustrate a point so i go over and
over so i was like no
no i need to delete that so it's really
at this point it's
really just a matter of um
cutting all the fat and getting to the
point cutting straight to the chase
um so yeah i'm spending quite a lot of
time right now just going through all of
that um cutting it all back
and making sure that i have um
illustrated the point in the most
exciting
fun sarcastic sassy manner
as possible because i feel like we need
it i feel like this space just
needs it okay so can you buy it in
bitcoin
go gotta take a drink silence is quite
interesting
just letting the silence you know just
settle
it's very interesting okay where can you
buy it so initially i was thinking um
to entirely self publish um
so i was going to create a shopify
website um where you could buy it in
bitcoin
um but i decided against that um
and that was quite a last minute
decision i definitely i'm dinard about
it for a while and the reason
that um i changed my mind is because i
want
everybody to have access to this book
and i don't know what tomorrow holds i
don't know
you know what if one day i get banned on
twitter um like i'm careful i try not to
what if this platform bans me you know
you just don't know
um so i wanted to
make sure that everybody had access to
it so it's going to be on amazon
and it's going to be
there's going to be kindle version
there's going to be a
paperback version and an audio
version um the audio version obviously i
haven't done yet because i haven't
finished tweaking the book
i say tweaking i'm basically rewriting
it at this point because i just
have some other ideas i want to like
switch it up um
so yeah it's gonna be on amazon so
unless you can buy bitcoin buy stuff on
amazon with bitcoin i don't think you'll
be able to buy my book with bitcoin um
unless maybe you don't like through
paypal like i was talking about earlier
you know um
that's kind of the only way that i can
think about it um okay so the cover
okay so i'm not gonna tell you what the
cover's like just yet you guys i might
actually put um
a vote out because there are two that i
really like um but the one that i have
in mind
it's have you guys seen the film um
molly's game
let me know if you've seen it it's
basically very casino vibes
this woman starts this um this big
gambling thing and anyway it's got those
vibes it's got very vegas vibes
um and yeah it's definitely gonna be a
head turner something give me a head
turner but hey who cares i want it to be
a head turner like i want to have as
much fun with it as possible
you know disrupt make things happen
make it exciting i don't want to just
like like look
people super successful people never
successful people always rock the boat
they never like just fit in because if
you fit in
you're just gonna get lost in a crowd of
hundreds of thousands of people
i don't want my book to be lost in a
crowd of hundreds of thousands of people
i spent a lot of time on this
um and it means a lot to me like i'm
dedicating this live stream to it
so you know i don't want to
yeah i don't want to fit in with it um
yes i will
be voicing the audio book
somebody said poker in the hotel yes
that is molly's game poke it in the
hotel room so you know how like it's
really
sassy and it's stylish
that's the front cover so very stylish
so i'm very excited
um okay so we have been doing this for
40 minutes now
and i've been working all day so i'm
super tired so i'm gonna log off in a
second
but log off do we say that anymore but
um if you do have any more questions
then just drop it in the comments
section below
and i will answer them all now
i'm reading your comments is it helpful
for amateurs
of course look the book
is supposed to be something which you
will enjoy as somebody who's already in
crypto
but also your parents will enjoy and
find
funny honestly the book like i
rewrote the first chapter today and it's
actually hilarious
like it's actually funny there are
things that i've written in there
where i'm just like i can't believe i
just wrote that but hey it's really
really funny
um oh and i said that everybody gets
roasted in the first chapter
americans get roasted in the first
chapter sorry
okay all right if you have any more
questions let me know
because i'm running out of water and
um i won't be able to continue once this
is done
it's done all right guys
i'm waiting for a few more questions and
then i'm going to head out
let's have a look what we have here you
didn't say how much bitcoin
you have yeah i get paid in bitcoin come
on
oh well thank you to ryan kramer very
much
do i trade forex no i don't i don't
trade
that's something i haven't mentioned
have i i don't trade um
i mean look like okay i trade but i
don't trade how you would imagine like
leverage trading
margin trading all that stuff i don't
get involved in that at all
um the reason i don't get involved in
that is because um
you it requires a lot of um
skill experience and also time to
watch the market in that way um oh
hang on there we go oh thank you ryan
kramer and there's another one
you rock ryan everyone follower on
twitter she's fun and edgy that's nice
thank you
to the ron there you go very cool um
what was i saying oh yeah so it requires
a lot of trading requires a lot of time
energy skill and so i would say to those
who
aren't professional traders or who
haven't spent a lot of time trading to
be very very careful when it comes to it
the trading that i do is buying a bunch
of oats in a bear market
then when the alts go right up in a bull
market i sell and take my profits and
live a good life
you know bitcoin i certainly don't trade
absolutely not i don't have the time the
energy to time a market
i'm not in the business to time a market
that's exhausting for me i have too much
to do you know i got these shows to do
i got a book to write so yeah i
certainly don't have
um the the energy to do that i totally
commend the people that do
um because i don't have it in me um
maybe one day
um okay i will take one last question
an amount of water
somebody says will there be any signed
copies of my book undressing bitcoin
okay so just on that point like i said
i'm going to be in the states
um and you guys are more than welcome
to come to a meet-up that i'm going to
host um just obviously if you're
watching me on
um twitter then i'll announce the dates
and the
location of the meetup coming very very
soon um
so yeah follow that on twitter i'll be
mentioning those dates
and then bring the book and i will sign
it
but because it's going through amazon i
won't be able to physically have a book
to send it to you and to sign
so um so so yeah i won't be able to do
that unless we all meet in person which
we are more than welcome to do
in the coming few weeks when i head to
america
all right my friends firstly thank you
so so much for tuning in
um it's been really really cool this is
very very different i've never
i never usually do this i think i might
do more of them um usually i always have
a guest and we sit down and we
and we talk about things um but this
time it's it's just me it's just leia
i'm talking about my book
so it's been really really nice thank
you so much for all your engagement
um it's been really really fun i loved
looking through all the comments
uh someone has just said they just tuned
in and you'll have to come back next
week
because this is the end of it now but um
thank you all so much
for tuning in and i will catch you all
on twitter because i
have an addiction and i'm on there too
much all right bye bye
[Applause]